well let's trust and sick here start I'm
a happy leading tributes to the queen
this afternoon in Parliament the former
prime minister Theresa May was among the
MPS paying tribute to the queen in the
House of Commons she had the chamber in
stitches with one particular anecdote
I remember one picnic at Balmoral which
was taking place in one of the bosses on
the estate the hampers came from the
castle and we all mucked in to put the
food and drink out on the table
I picked up some cheese put it on a
plate and was transferring it to the
table
the cheese fell on the floor
I had a split second decision to make
[Laughter]
I picked up the cheese put it on the
plate and put it on the table
and I turned around to see that my every
move
I've been watched very carefully by her
majesty the queen
I looked at her she looked at me
and she just smiled
and the cheese remained on the table
well I'm glad to say we can now speak
large the former prime minister Theresa
May it was such a a lovely anecdote you
tell there and a very good afternoon to
you Theresa May and and just sticking
with that what that Illustrated about
her majesty was just I suppose how Rye
dry knowing and a little bit mischievous
she was
well I think that well certainly what
came through but also just a kind of
down-to-earth common sense
um uh in terms of her approach to the uh
to the issue um but that that sort of
slightly mischievous nature that twinkle
in the eye that sense of fun was all
part of her majesty the queen alongside
obviously the very serious side of the
queen but it was good to be able
particularly in more relaxed moments at
Balmoral to enjoy that sense of fun and
that more mischievous side
I think it's good for us the public to
know that the head of state and the
Prime Minister you know are regular
human beings who can relax
well indeed and certainly relax was one
of the things that the queen was always
very keen that her guests at Balmoral
were able to do she I think found
Balmoral the most relaxing place that
that she was able to stay at she she
loved Balmoral and the Scottish
Countryside and she wanted everybody
else to enjoy that as well and so she
went out of her way to make sure that
the Prime Minister and and in my case my
husband when we went up there for the
weekend could really enjoy it she chose
some of the books that were put in the
room that we were staying in uh you know
always trying to make sure that her
guests felt at ease were comfortable and
were able to enjoy their time there
tell me about that experience in the
chamber of the House of Commons today it
was quite a remarkable for us to to
watch from outside but but but being
inside that chamber with the whole
chamber MP small sides of the house just
United in their appreciation of what has
now passed
well indeed and it was it's a remarkable
time it's one of those times when I
think the House of Commons comes into
its own absolutely packed everybody
obviously somberly dressed and initially
very very somber recognizing that we
were grieving and mourning the loss of a
very remarkable woman are monarch the
late uh Queen Elizabeth II
you could have heard a picture
sorry you could have heard of pin drops
during the opening speeches
um and then every tribute thereafter
people were telling their own anecdotes
of their experience of meeting her
majesty the queen
one thing that really Shone out that I
really picked up from as you say the
wonderful tributes in anecdotes was that
it's as public servants yourself you can
tell when someone is way way better at
it than you that's that's selfless
devotion to duty
absolutely I mean it was one of the
marks of her majesty if you remember she
she said when she was 21 that she would
devote her life to the service of her
people and of people and that is exactly
what she did my goodness me uh a life a
well-lived life but a life full of
service she would never shy away from
her Duty she would never shy away we saw
that from the fact that only a few days
ago on Tuesday she was had an audience
of the new prime minister Liz truss now
that was part of her role it was part of
her Duty and she wanted to carry on
doing her work doing her service to the
country right to what turned out to be
very close to the end
and what we've been finding out is of
course that service to the country well
we saw it externally and maybe
superficially in the public appearances
so many thousands I guess hundreds of
thousands of those over the 70 years but
it was things that people like you saw
and I know you can't share any of the
conversations that passed between you uh
during those audiences with her majesty
when you were prime minister but we know
that you when you were in those meetings
could see that you were talking to
somebody who wasn't just ticking the box
as head of state there was some real
wise counsel to be given
indeed and I think that was one of the
reasons why her majesty was so
remarkable uh because we've talked about
the Devotion to duty but she was hard
working she had a red box every day she
would read the papers in the red box so
she knew what the issues of the day were
she knew that the challenges that the
government was having to Grapple with
but she had a enormous experience born
obviously of her length of time on the
The Throne so towards the latter years
of of her Reign that experience could be
brought to bear but she was also very
wise she was a very good judge of people
uh she was as I say Down to Earth had a
great Common Sense she understood her
people I think that was one of the
crucial things about her and she was
able to bring all that together in in a
sense of how you know she felt on some
of the issues that that were being
considered and the government was was
looking at and critically it was
somebody who was above politics who
didn't have a political angle to come
from she was coming from the angle of an
understanding of knowledge and
experience
now of course the vast majority of us in
the country have all grown up with only
one head of state we've ever known of
course a Majesty the queen was she an
inspiration to you as you were
developing your career of Public Service
well I think that um I was asked a while
back why it was that the UK had managed
to have at that stage two female prime
ministers now of course three and I I
did say that I think actually the UK was
used to having a woman as a leader
because we had her majesty on the throne
for all those years as our head of state
so there wasn't a hang up in the UK
about having a woman as prime minister
because we'd had a woman as Queen as
leader of the country for so many years
and yes when you look back at Her
Majesty's life when you consider and
this was one of the contributions in the
House of Commons today was from Harriet
Harman who spoke about the challenge
that the queen would have faced when she
acceded to the throne at the young age
of 25 at a time when the expectation was
that women didn't take leadership roles
that women weren't outspoken that men
were the dominant the man was the
dominant one in any couple and she
managed with her grace and her charm and
her Devotion to duty to to show woman a
woman in a very critical leadership role
and I think that was an inspiration to
many
that is a hugely important Point thank
you so much for making it send them just
lastly I'm sure you've been asked this
question quite a lot but we all know you
know you've rubbed shouldered hobnobed
or whatever with world leaders the Great
and the good how did her majesty measure
up to the others that you met
oh well there's absolutely no hesitation
in saying she was the most impressive
um you know I'm often asked that
question who who was the most who most
impressed you as a world leader that you
met and I have absolutely no hesitation
in saying every time that the head of
state who I found most impressive was
Queen Elizabeth II
marvelous memory Teresa May thank you
very very much indeed for joining us on
Sky News thank you